what is tax hello my name is too cute I
design rocket-propelled clothes I came
to earth because I am fascinated by your
shoes there is no such thing on my
planet I have a great idea I will design
rocket-propelled shoes Europeans love
shoes I will make my shoes in the
European Union but I read that if I
start a business I have a lot of
responsibilities like paying tax I must
find out more about tax come with me
let's investigate
[Music]
that was that they will have to give up
one of them can afford to build the
playground
what and give money so that others can
also enjoy the park why the young
Earthlings are amazing got their parents
involved too so that's what common
contribution means taxes are common
contributions just like those I wonder
what you can achieve with all that tax
money who pays for the public lighting
humans talk about bills all the time but
no one says anything about this who
built these roads look someone even
fills in the potholes who pays for that
who pays so that these people keep them
safe they get to learn for free how come
[Music]
and they have someone to take care of
them they get hurt
[Music]
or if something bad happens how is this
possible
[Music]
that's where the money comes from taxes
everybody contributes so that everybody
can benefit
just like those amazing kids did let's
get something straight
do I have to pay tax if I open my rocket
shoe shop yes you will pay taxes for
example you will pay tax on the income
you obtain aha I pay a part of the
profit as tax because I use all these
public services to make that profit
sounds fair
are there exceptions from this rule yes
there are situations where we don't pay
taxes am i one of these exceptions if
you have your own income or owned a
house or buy and sell things you will
pay tax that's clear and how much do I
need to pay according to your ability to
pay huh
that's a relief well can I give some of
the shoes I designed in order to pay my
taxes
unfortunately no you can't taxes are
only paid in money yeah thought so
but do I really have to pay tax the
question you need to ask yourself is
this one
do you enjoy way equipped hospitals to
feel secure good roads modern schools oh
yeah I really appreciate that you see
neither these would exist without
everyone's contribution including yours
got it more resources collected from
taxes mean better public services so
let's get this straight I am one of you
now so I have to pay taxes like anyone
else
yep that's the law taxes are my
contribution to the public services I
enjoy I can use public services freely
but they don't come for free we all pay
for them even kids because we need them
in order to have a better life I will
need money to pay them hmm that may be a
problem but I will pay according to what
I earn that's good
since Rocky's shoes are not the easiest
things to sell around here you know what
taxes seems such a complicated subject
couldn't understand what they are and
why you pay them I had no idea how they
work and why they are important but the
kids helped me figure it out
because they decided to contribute and
build what they needed rather than sit
back and not get involved they chose to
stick together and support each other
and everybody got something out of it
love this planet Texas and all
that's my take on taxes what do you
think do you benefit from any of the
things which are funded through taxes
did you know you already paid taxes how
does it feel
[Music]